the history of warfare did you start
working on this book hello 40 years ago
when did you first get interested in
warfare I couldn't help being interested
right here at 50 years ago when I was 10
years old the place was alive with the
apparatus of war we were all interested
if you were 10 years old
the streets were crammed with many
American soldiers soldiers anyhow but
mainly American soldiers American
equipment American aeroplanes I've had
quite a lot of British aeroplanes too
but towards him where we are now was
almost an American town in april/may and
the beginning of June 1944 they were
waiting to go to d-day and this was the
this was one of the main American
concentration areas what do you remember
from those days ah jeeps jeeps are the
thing I remember most because nobody
thing that had ever seen anything like a
Jeep and if you were 10 years old
it made an even stronger impression
every ten-year-old English boy wanted to
have a drive in a jeep and I did get a
drive in a Jeep - which was a tremendous
excitement but I suppose it's very
difficult not to impose but if your
historian not to impose your subsequent
memories on what you'd actually do
remember but I'd the Americans would if
I think they were cause different to
twelve English people but they were even
different to English children there they
were American they weren't they were
much more extroverted and cheerful and
good-natured and everything that's
Americans are supposed to be and that
that is a very strong impression from
those times what what was this area used
for as far as staging was concerned when
I was a military ER there was an
enormous Hospital here is he takes the
the everybody all the commanders
Eisenhower Montgomery they all expected
they
very heavy casualties on d-day they
thought there would be tens of thousands
of wounded on the beaches and that
they'd have to be treated here back here
in Britain said the Americans because
this was an American area they built an
enormous hospital here and it still
exists and it is torn Tain's main
hospital it it shares what American
prefabrication of fifty years ago could
could do and it was a supply area and
there were airfields there were glider
airfields for taking the the puppy the
glider board infantry to to net
whereabouts or some areas where the 82nd
money one Airborne Division's were going
and I think there was just everything
really I would have to reconstruct some
sort of map which probably difficult to
find ideas but to a child's eye there
was everything how many books should be
written
counting slight of works about twenty
eyes affairs which ones done the best
face of battle much I'd published in
1976 in a curious way it's always called
a classics I suppose it is a classic
what I put it was not a difficult book
to write I knew exactly what I was going
to say before I began it just came out
it was not a difficult book to write in
the way that this was because um I was
trying to put so much that I know into
such a small space in a history of
warfare your books do better in Great
Britain or in the United States the
United States without any question
except courtesy for this one this one's
been enormous ly successful in Britain
and there's one on a major literary
prize but I have a great American
readership it's not the only reason I
did love the United States but it's one
of the reasons why do you think he
appeal to Americans I did no I went to
America when I was very young
I've been there many many times in my
life and I think I've got a feel for
America it's certainly a country that I
deeply devoted to tremendously
interested in that's not really an
answer to the question I think Americans
like they like the practical they like
the human and I like both those things
myself and I try and put them into my
books I like to try and pick problems to
pieces in a practical way and also pick
them to pieces in a human way and I
think that Pat's it's not a deliberate
formula but it may be the faithful
matter that appeals to American readers
you can't pick up many of your books
without learning that you write the Java
limp
well it's getting worse what's it from
it's from orthopedic tuberculosis which
is a lot thank goodness is a
banish'd disease now nobody gets it but
it was very common when I was young I
tax tax the bone joints and it leaves
you damaged in some way or other
when did you contract the disease about
13 just the end of the war and just
before they invented the drugs which
cure the disease but two years before
doctors look at me and they say you were
unlucky too weren't you and I said yes
another two years and I would have been
cured what impact has it had on your
life
I don't in a cure I'm beginning to
regret it now because I am getting
rather lame and
I've gotta be 60 this year and the last
year it's been a nuisance hasn't been a
nuisance the rest of the times but
hasn't scarcity affected my life at all
and in an odd way getting a very strange
teenage years because I was in flat on
my back in bed the year after year and
in Ward full of young men who come back
from the war I didn't regret that in an
old way I didn't have get a proper
education but I did get a strange sort
of view on life and I think people who
commonly said that people who've been
ill in childhood and have had an upset
education never really regret that they
do unless they were absolutely deprived
of course I wasn't deprived but it's I
think it's so I think it's a spur to a
writ not not that one should claim
originality but I think it means that
you don't look at the world in the way
that other people do and perhaps if
you're inclined to be a writer that's a
help why do you mention it in your books
sorry why do you mention the lamp in the
book because I'm a military historian
and I've never been to war and there
must be some explanations that I've
never been in the army I've never worn
uniform no in the Navy or the Air Force
so I have to have a reason I have a very
good reason which is that the medical
officer the the Army Recruiting Center
took one look at me and sign me off I
mean I'm completely unfit for military
service when did you know then that you
wanted to write about war but don't know
I think that it was this wartime thing
of being here just before d-day and
seeing these extraordinary things
happening I was little white people
interested in history little boys some
little boys are interested in history
some hard I was I'd always
being interested from five or six I can
remember liking sort of child's history
books more than the other sort of
child's but the parents talk history my
father was very interested indeed and
had been a soldier in the First World
War and that was an influence but
besides that I can't really explain I
you have to choose a subject eventually
if you go to university which i did and
i trace history i was what i was
interested in and then you had to choose
a special subject a major I suppose and
I chose military history because that
seemed the most interested being on
offer and then I got stuck in a groove
where'd you guys go I Oxford what school
which College available now is there
something special about Berio that does
deals with history it's got some very
distinguished historians it's also got a
very strong pacifist tradition an
anti-war tradition too so that may be a
bit of a an oddity are you a pacifist
95% what's the vibe
there are certain wicked people in the
world that you can't deal with except by
force the most wicked in your lifetime
Hitler without dart I think that I think
Hitler was seriously seriously wicked
not mad twisted a lot of the Bolsheviks
were simply dreadful to bat Satan was
terrible the great men of power who seek
to change the nation's they belong to
usually are pretty terrible people
that 5% then allows what if you it
allows the use of extreme force in a
measured way if possible in a measured
way in order to curtail or or extinguish
the activities of these wicked men were
talking about you have a couple of
figures in your book the history a
history of warfare
by the way just a quick question why
didn't you call it the history of work I
didn't think there is the history I
think that can only be history is each
one of each rule to be called a history
because ultimately it's a personal view
you pointed out early in the book that
some 20 million people had died in the
First World War and another 50 million
in the Second World War how well in the
first world war they were mainly killed
by direct an attraction there wasn't
much collateral death as it's come to be
called AI bombing all all because
civilian deaths as a byproduct of
fighting Omaha it was people in uniform
that got killed the probably 10 million
uniformed it's a bit difficult to get it
quite right the others were the victims
of hardship privation starvation disease
was a huge for example influenza
epidemic at the end of the First World
War which would have come anyhow but had
a greater effect because there was such
malnutrition particularly in Central
Europe that's a moral war I'm afraid in
the Second World War there are a lot of
collateral deaths ie what 2 million
Germans killed by bombing probably a
million Japanese killed by both
civilians we're talking on civilians
killed by bombing civilians find
themselves in the direct line of fire of
the first time in in the warfare of
civilized nations rarely and then there
was a lot of
again a lot of pride the death through
privation malnutrition and more later
disease but also of course a lot of
atrocity of course there was the
deliberate genocide of the hip Hitler
genocide policy against Jews against
Paris other nationalities 9 origins who
were on his Black is but there were also
there was all there also the atrocities
of partisan warfare particularly in
Eastern Europe and in China I think you
probably you'd probably get 10 or 15
million battle deaths and the rest would
be collateral deaths civilian deaths
what's the 80 years range for your book
from the Stone Age to modern times which
is how many years well Homo sapiens you
and me hem a sapiens sapiens has been
about for 40,000 years and that's a it's
the last 40,000 years really has there
ever been a book written like this one
or two but not many people have had a go
at the whole thing it is it is a bit
arrogant arrogant oh yes I think so
why do you say error well you have
you're pretending that you inevitably
you're pretending that you know most
world history which I clearly did you
have chapters that say flesh iron and
stone how did you block out that book I
blocked it out over very long period
thinking about it thinking about I
wanted I suppose I eventually wanted to
write to try and put this extraordinary
phenomenon I mean men killing other men
and sometimes other women to not not
very very infrequently women killing
except in the hope of course but not you
know not for public purposes are very
rarely women killing women men men
killing other men read it is
extraordinary phenomenon why does why
does it happen I wanted and hollows had
gone on and have the motifs changed and
clearly the methods of change but have a
late history I I want I think I wanted
to do it I think I wanted to do it
before I knew I wanted to do it but
eventually I knew I wanted to do it and
that meant beginning beginning right at
the beginning and it also meant having
some means of organizing it and you
can't do it chronologically if you start
at the beginning and go on to the end
century by century the book would be
that thick you had to have some way of
dropping it down and so I in the end hit
on the idea of what was the dominant
technology really it's not a technology
book but I really in the end that I
thought that was the only way of
simplifying
organizing it said stay in weapons and
then there's this long period when when
weapons have appeared but the the real
instrument war is the horse from about a
thousand BCE to a thousand ad bit longer
maybe they're what two thousand years
when the horse peoples were the great
warriors of the world and dominated them
dominated every bit of the world where
you could keep large horse herds luckily
you can't in Western Europe but
elsewhere they dominated where do you
find where if there is such a place the
bulk of the background material needed
to write something book like a book like
this well the years I taught at Santos
which is Britain's West Point which has
the most wonderful I mean truly the best
wonderful library it's a library whose
origins go back
into the 18th century I tires in a very
beautiful building it has very liberal
rules about borrowing and working and
and that's one of the ideas as far as
I'm concerned the perfect library and
most most of what I know in life I
learnt in the Sandhurst library where is
Santa it's just outside London about 20
miles west of Heathrow to orientate
American travelers to this country how
big is it
it's it's it was built in the adjustor
the end of the age of 18 beginning the
19th century on a very beautiful piece
of park land it's looks like a
gentleman's mansion Yale building it
looks as if I don't have fallow deer
grazing in the in the park it almost
does not quite it's got a bug it's about
quota the size of West Point it has less
than a thousand cadets whereas of course
West Point now has over 4,000 cadets
and it is not as if it slope the West
Point has a simply enormous training
area in which it sits Santos has
gradually lost that as Londoners crept
out towards it but it remains accuracy a
tranquil oasis in spreading suburbia how
long did you teach there 25 years very
far too long
nobody should teach anywhere for 25
years but what did you teach at military
history exclusively again nobody should
teach military history for 25 years I
did why did you do so interested I love
the place I like the people it's one of
the most beautiful places I've ever seen
on earth curiosity it has got strange
theatrical quality to it
my children were very happy there we had
a eventually we graduated as people do
from from very humble merit
quarters we went up the scale eventually
we lived in a very nice house the
children we had four children who grew
up there and I think they loved the
surroundings my wife didn't but she gave
him because the children night and I
liked it and so I stayed and I kept on
segued myself as time went on I must not
I must not stay here forever
otherwise I shall become a vegetable of
I think I nearly did when did you leave
in 1986
then what well the friend of mine who
fell in at his door and although he was
he was also extremely successful and
well-known journalist called Max
Hastings telephoned me one day to say
that he'd been offered the editorship of
the Daily Telegraph and did did he think
did I think he should take it so I said
oh well max you didn't really think you
need to ask me that question I anyhow a
conversation developed in the course of
which he said and if you'd like to be
the defense editor when I get to be
editor why don't you come so I said yes
and he said what I get to see the new
era and I'll telephone you in two days
and he did and he said if you want to
come do come when that was the end of it
you're sitting in a room it's a couple
of hours in London do you operate from
here as a Daily Telegraph defense
correspondent I gave London about two or
three days a week and but now of course
we're also electronic that you can sit
you can sit in your house in the West
Country and type into the paper or fax
into the paper it's just an impediment
at all now this book a history of
warfare is targeted to what audience who
do you envision buying this book well I
hope my fellow historians like it and
some do and some don't but I've never
really written
my fellow historians what I've always
wanted to do is write the sort of book
which fellow historians would have to
take seriously but which was really a
book for the educated general reader who
would like to be informed to have his
view of the world enlarged about a
particular subject and I think this is
the highest of all historical callings I
utterly I always despise and I think I
do despise the the direction that a
university history writing has taken in
which annul enormous effort years of
work given to writing books which really
only interest a few hundred others
address problems which only a few dozen
others are aware of as problems at all
and increasingly use language which
perhaps any other academics can
understand that seems to me to be a
diversion of the historians cooling the
historian all right for historian ought
to be an educated person writing for
other educated people about something
which the they don't know by but wish to
know about in a way that they can
understand you put the emphasis a couple
of times uneducated
what do you mean educated I suppose I
would mean what Jefferson meant I've got
a rather eighteenth-century view of what
being educated is which is uh
having read the major works of
literature having having an
understanding of the broad periods of
history and which the world's past is
divided perhaps speaking another
language or at least being aware of
other languages and having some
competence I don't think education
having some special competence that
often because those ought to go with it
too but I don't think education and I
don't look to find an educated person in
the ranks of university graduates
necessarily some of the educated
educated people I know never be near a
university you had a book a couple years
ago the history of world war two yeah
was that a different audience you were
writing for them than this one not for
me in fact my publishers then rather
marketed as such I said I went
complained because it's so little
Norma's numbers but I was I did think it
was aimed at of perhaps or slightly I
did say narrower market but they let one
of what I think is is when I'd saw what
the book looked like it didn't seem to
be the sort of manuscript I'd written
he'd looked at a more popular book than
I had intended it to be
Clausewitz the name is almost on every
page in hell how come well I think
perhaps I may have overdone that a bit
but there's awful German who died in
1830 born 1780
he's absolutely dominates the way his
military history is written and what's
worse state military policy is formed he
relentlessly argues that war is
the is the military is well the famous
raises war is the extension of policy by
other means the more as a form is a a
form of political activity I did of
course sometimes it is but sometimes it
isn't I don't think that what's going on
in Bosnia at the moment is is political
activity it's partly political but it's
partly atavistic as well people are
behaving in a in a in a way which
doesn't bear political explanation but
it does bear and for logical explanation
or cultural explanations
what is Ana visting me going back to
one's earliest forefathers I think I
think the Mongols were all the steppe
Turks who who created the role of steppe
Turks who created them part which the
Muslims in Bosnia belonged would
understand what's going on because they
were violent cruel clever cunning people
who backtick closets who was he
he was a Russian son of a clergyman born
8 1788 served in Prussian army captured
by the French changed sides when
Napoleon invaded Prussia went to fight
for the Russians never made a great
success his military career he was a
difficult cantankerous man he was
regarded with suspicion because he
taught for the Russians even though it
that was in the cause of Prussian
independence and he was sort of
pensioned off said to the staff cottage
to live out his days where he sat down
and wrote this great I mean it has to be
said great theoretical work called on
wall which was influenced every soldier
and statesman interest in war for the
last hundred years recent times oh sure
it's tool and
go into any of the United States Armed
Forces staff cottages and pick up the
[ __ ] a common curriculum and you will
see the name class of its half a dozen
times and they'll because this
discussion of the the applicability of
class fits to modern times very little
questioning of whether class fits was
right or wrong has wits is pretty well
still gospel in service schools in the
in the English german-speaking world's
is he worth it I think he I think he
well what I'd like to say is that he
doesn't describe war but he perverts
politics in the beginning of the book
you dedicate this book to winter
Bridgman who was he an ancestor I don't
think that's a direct ancestor I think
more kinsman my mother's family will
call Bridgman they came from Southwest
Ireland but they weren't the sort of
Irish who were originally English the so
called ascendancy they they came as
conquerors and they were given land the
other half may the keikain half of
course with a lot ii were there in the
first place and who on the hill got land
taken away from them where did you pick
him international sort of I wouldn't
call it a mercenary but it's
international professional officer who
sailed his services he died in the
service of the French there are an awful
lot of people liking in the book I think
his international professional military
experts are numa significant in the and
the history of warfare particularly in
carrying skills technologies too but
particularly skills from one society to
another and transforming the military if
you say in the in the introduction of
the book that worries wholly unlike
diplomacy or politics because it must be
fought by men whose values and skills
are not those of politicians or
diplomats explain
well I think first of all people who
undergo professional military training
like West pointers and people who dare
to sound to us do turn out different
it's a more complete training education
there isn't really a good English where
there's a very good French where
adventures their formation I think that
people who get West Point or sound house
literally are formed or untransformed
and they become different from others
they they have automatic reactions of
duty and meeting standards which the
rest of us don't that's one thing the
other thing is I think that inside this
group there is and you don't necessarily
find them inside the professional
military group you can find them outside
too but inside this professional
military group you do find people who
trust you cannot imagine in any other
setting they've just seen to be warriors
and they seem to be recognized by the
others as natural warriors it's a bit
like saying asking asking how to
identify them as a bit like asking how
to identify supremely handsome or
beautiful human beings you can't but
when you see them you know them they're
there I think if you could observe them
in action you would understand and be
able to describe but because of the
secret nature of warfare you can't but
they are like there's sportsmen who
can't be anything but sportsmen and who
you can identify because you can see
them running faster than anybody else or
or playing games better than anyone
Gill's you are right below that say war
is wholly unlike diplomacy or politics
because it must be fought by men whose
values and skills are not those of
politicians or diplomats no what's the
difference between the values of the
politicians diplomats and soldiers i
said soldier it's necessary quality of a
diplomat or or a politician that he will
compromise and indeed we we on the whole
don't want to be led by uncompromising
politicians or diplomats they'd get you
into the most terrible trouble on the
other hand soldiers among themselves
when committed to a task can't
compromise because they may that is that
it compromise it's the opposite on the
battlefield
it's compromise its compromise which
will get you into trouble it's only
unrelenting devotion to the standards of
duty and courage absolute loyalty to
others not letting the task go until
it's been done that will get you through
that's why they're different when i ask
you about some more is that the
americans have been involved in get your
analysis on what was the vietnam war all
about as relates as it relates to
history
I will never oppose the Vietnam War I
thought that the Americans were right to
do it
I think they fought it in the wrong way
but I think they were right to to oppose
the attempt spy gear by Ho Chi Minh and
gap to to make the whole of Vietnam into
a Marxist society and looking to looking
what's happened to the country since I'd
still believed that it was right to try
and stop them
I think it was a responsible effort by
the United States they fought the war in
the wrong way they fought the war with
in particular the what was wrong about
it was at their innocence sodas there
for one year so it couldn't be run as a
proper war it was it was run with one
eye on public opinion the whole time let
me go back to your thing about being a
pacifist is that your 5 percent coming
out yes I I I wouldn't have felt it was
the end of the world the war hadn't been
fought it's not that kind of war I don't
think as a war like fighting hit but I
think it was a correct war rightful and
I it's it had indirect effects of the
greatest importance as well I think it
demonstrated to the Russians of the
Russian leadership of the last years of
communism that the Americans were
serious when they said that they opposed
common ISM and I think it therefore
contributed eventually to the end of the
Cold War the fall of the full befall of
Commodus regimes all over Central and
Eastern Europe we ask you about terms
did the Americans lose the Vietnam War
ultimately yes I think they did did
general zap when yes oh he certainly won
how did they do it against what was
rather expensive military machine they
did it because they did not send young
men to war for one year they sent them
south 50,000 I think it was every year
they sent fresh I made what that fing
wrong and maybe in 250,000 every year
they could send out to their young
manhood they could send that number
south and they didn't come back until
the war was over they either got killed
or they went all
extraordinary effort of national
determination it was really national
determination against the only semi
national determination why was general
Zapp successful with the French same
thing well he was up curacy in some ways
against a more purposeful army because
the French the French did not gave one
year they went for long tours but in the
end of course they were outnumbered the
the the French codename they couldn't
send conscripts to Vietnam they could
only send regular soldiers and
mercenaries from Africa and many Africa
you talked a lot about Mao Zedong in the
book but don't mention we do match him
don't mention a lot about Ho Chi Minh
well how does he fit in in world history
um I didn't give it I didn't mention how
Chi Minh and and yeah because they all
say much the pupils of Marseille too and
I felt if I don't dad said what might
Satan's particular methods were you
didn't need two more examples bad Satan
had this extraordinary idea of
politicizing minute sort of militarizing
politicizing and militarizing very
ordinary humble people who stood on the
margins of Chinese society and of
attacking the centres of Chinese power
from far away
by indirect means whether the thing
would have worked if the Japanese had
not stuffing out of Chiang kai-shek and
the Chinese national army before potato
got going in 1946 I don't that I suspect
the mouth it was a great deal of his
success to the Japanese
but even if he even if that's not even
if that is true he nevertheless his
message was sufficiently correct and
certainly sufficiently powerful to do
enormous damage elsewhere outside China
in in Vietnam for example and then later
in North Africa in their black Africa
going back to class words if you would
have found Hitler in his den reading
about war would he be
would he have read class would in in his
last will and testament written in the
bunker in Berlin with Russian shells
thudding overhead
he mentioned only one name and it was
the name of class roots now if you could
see you know when he was live Mao Zedong
sitting somewhere reading about war who
would he be reading I don't think he
would I think he'd be reading the great
Chinese classics um su & Co who say
different things I mean close mud said
John was not trust with you he said what
the great Chinese classics have always
said that is better not to fight that
the clever man achieved his ends without
violence that a battle delayed is better
than a battle fought etc etc I'm in the
child the Chinese have a different
conception of war they in which time
rather than action is the is the
defining dimension who is Sen su o he
may cannot have existed in the very
ancient Chinese writer of two thousand
years BC but he's the first to have
codified this Chinese attitude towards
war which is
immensely formidable if it's opposed by
Western methods which always looking for
decisions results since time is precious
now if we could find you and your den
and your happiest of moves reading what
would you be reading I'm not military
history I only do that for work I would
be reading my favorite English authors
and American authors who are they
depends where I am when I was at
Princeton as a fellow in 1984 by myself
my wife and children were home in
England I became afflicted by cultural
homesick sea sickness and I read the
whole of them Jane Austen in about 2 or
3 weeks again but I wouldn't say I read
Jane Austen in England curiously because
I live in such from Jane Austen
surroundings I don't need to trollop
particularly the Antonia trollop
particularly the church narwhals for all
the political novels
Kipling to whom I'm absolutely devoted I
think is one of the supreme geniuses of
English literature for pure relaxation
when just a sort of a sort of tree tied
up forward - which will make me feel
better in life John Buchan Americans
Hemingway Melville a very keen on
Melville as a poet Whitman over here on
Whitman has appeared the the novelist of
the thirties likes likes time neck I'm
there's a New Yorker short piece writer
whom I adore called Joseph Mitchell
whose works have just being collected
and reissued he's they have cooled up at
the old hotel
I think extraordinary pictures of
American Seana life if you're reading
military history as he there's an
American called drawn will marching has
only ever written one book who I ignore
masti admirer
I wish he'd write his second book first
book is one of the greatest advances on
later there's ever been it's called
gunpowder and galleys and it's about
Mediterranean naval warfare in the
sixteenth century
absolutely astonishing book what about
class woods
Sun Tzu Karl Marx hmm just read them
because I have to that's work no I I
very much bah
Barbara Tuchman as the guns of August I
think she's a wonderful writer at the
sort of level I admire sort of an expert
who writes rather education people that
are not quite expert level I think
that's tremendously important go back to
the pacifist thing we took a tour of the
Imperial War Museum in London and our
guide was a passage you write about
military history in your passage not
quite not quite five million you're the
defence editor of The Daily Telegraph
what's the politics what's the what's
the what's the slant of the daily to
so it's the conservative newspaper mean
it is although not officially the party
newspaper of the Conservative Party it
is it is regarded as being the the Ark
of the Covenant of conservative opinion
in this country does that make you a
conservative I did very conservative in
the last two or three elections I have
Lou is very conservative and the the
alternatives aren't much of an
attraction at the moment in this country
but I'm I'm not a member of the
Conservative Party correct the image
then the image of a conservative is
pro-military shop does that make them I
mean one the American conservatives
hearing you say how could he be a
pacifist almost and be a conservative
center no difficulty at all
III think that even a pacifist I think
should admire the military virtuous
should admire and indeed the best
pacifists have those virtues themselves
self-abnegation and willingness if
necessary to sacrifice their lives what
they believe I mean that is the ultimate
military virtue of that I will lay down
my life is called upon to do so it's and
duties obligate that's ultimately what
makes when I say so does a different
that's what ultimately makes owed is
different but I went choose whether I
will or not they doubt my life I have
already promised that I will it is for
swarm it is given away I will say a
soldier has mortgaged his life he said
here is my life and I can only have it
back again when the end of my service
comes and I
salute for the last time and take my
pension I think the pacifist is the same
except perhaps he his willingness to
sacrifice his life never goes this is
your 20th book you say where do you put
it on the list of your personal
favorites I enjoyed writing it a
normalcy more than anything I've ever
written when I write the face of battle
I felt I knew what the only time in my
life I knew what Kipling meant when he
said that a sort of diamond a sort of
spirit descends and you the book your
pan moves in an in an unconscious way I
didn't feel that for this it was an
effort but I still enjoyed writing it
very much indeed how do you write now
increasingly by pen I've got every sort
of writing instrument named
forever a word processor to a to a
fountain pen and a marvelously
unreliable 40 year old portable
typewriter which I do like writing on
but I increasingly I write trust with a
fountain pen in ink on lined paper
compared to what earlier I used to type
on on my on my portable I did have an
electric typewriter once which was a
monstrosity why'd you change I sorry to
bring it back here and I just get back
ache now if I type for long periods it's
easier - it's easier to write with a pen
where do you write in the room at the
head of the stairs on the second floor
of my house in the country looking out
over a very beautiful garden my wife's
created towards the edge of the chalk
plains of Salisbury playing that a
nonage fault which was put dug by the
Celtic people of Britain
so
laid century before Caesar conquered the
island oh he didn't talk before Augustus
conquered the islands in 43 ad does it
make a difference to you where you are
yes I'm very conscious with that in
front of the house just a few hundred
yards away runs a primitive track we
call the hard way which Alfred the Great
brought his army up from from Somerset
to fight the Danes at ethem dune in the
ninth century that means a great deal to
me Wendy right all dead 10 o'clock in
the morning till 7:30 at night with a
short break for lunch my wife is right a
to say we don't
she doesn't object too much gets a bit
what is she right she writes civilized
books biographies of she's ready to
biography of the wife of the compares of
Gustav Marla it was a very extraordinary
man in her in right what's her name Alma
mala my read is Suzanne Keegan and
published in the state yes
Alma her life of Allen Mara was a great
success and he's now writing the life of
the painter Oskar Kokoschka who was one
of Alma Marla's many lovers where did
you two meet in the house of a friend
when he was 22 when I was 24 what was
the attraction he's very very beautiful
what about the writing skills that's a
complete surprise to me and to her I
think she just started to do it one day
and hasn't stopped do you ever write
together
that's good she has a room we have a
long long thin house and she has a room
at one end and I have a robot the other
and children are for children of who
I've read to say all amaryllis in a sort
of trade my elder daughter was a
journalist for the Conde Nast
organization married an American my
elder son is a publisher for Simon &
Schuster
my younger son who is a twin is a
journalist and his twin sister is an
actress I'm afraid that were all in the
words business and what is your future
publishing plans and our Glu with
conifer on a contract basis I had said I
Denton fact have a condo that this was
not a two book contract but III think
there's no doubt I will publish for the
publisher for them next time round I
think they well I think they'd have
something to say to me if I did I'm
content right the author who we all
there's drawn a carrier as a friend of
mine and he said after reading that
there's nothing in it about intelligence
military intelligence that is and that's
planted the seed I've seen this book I'm
not sure you want to hear this there
look stacks of these books in stores in
the United States assuming that a lot of
it been sold before I got there this
seems to have been marketed a lot at
least around the Washington area how's
it selling very well I think I hope what
does that mean to you well how many does
it have to sell for you to say that was
a good well the the second world war
sewed in the United States in hardback
about between 80 and 90 thousand and
that for history book is very very good
indeed if that dances well I shall be
very pleased
could you make a living just writing
books oh I do now you mentioned that you
were the Daily Telegraph presented only
do that because I would go mad if I sat
at home in the country and write books
or my wife would kill me
um I mean I I work for the Daily
Telegraph because I find it extremely
interesting to do so but I am a
professional book writer you tell us in
the conclusion of your book that that
future when it comes to warfare is
brighter can you explain that and I may
be misquoting you but I know I did I did
I did irate that two years ago I don't
like to see what's happening around me
really I think the world's got I think
the world's taken a very nasty turn in
two years I did like what's happening I
think there will may be a way out of the
North Korean situation but I don't like
it I think that they have to be
prevented from becoming a nuclear power
that's the most pressing of all problems
at the moment the situation on the
fringe of Christian and Muslim lands
running from Bosnia into the Caucasus is
extremely unpleasant and there's I don't
seem I don't think we've seen even the
middle of it yet certainly not the end I
think that black Africa is a scream it
terrifying for black Africa I didn't
think it will affect the rest of the
world unfortunately I mean I think
that's part of the tragedy that the
black Africa can become a mild Strom of
warring tribes without the outside world
and needing to feel that it feeling a
need to do anything about it except of
course for the arm salesman to sell arms
into into the situation
there's the days of the three great
areas of unpleasant as that I identify
them which I think will got worse since
I since I finished rather optimistically
two years ago what caused you to finish
up domestically in the first place well
I finished writing that book in 1992 sat
right
three two and we were still very much
celebrating the end of the Cold War the
more civil war in Bosnia had not broken
aft there was nothing like the trouble
in their walls in South Africa we had a
very successful conclusion to the Gulf
War which looked as if the UN was all
there not strictly a gulf war are not
strictly a although the Gulf Wars it was
not strictly a UN war it was fort
nevertheless with UN approval everything
looked extremely positive for the future
of peacekeeping by the responsible party
as if Russia was moving from from from
its former unhappy state into one of
equal stability with the other large
part of the world so I think it was
possible to be optimistic I'm still Oh
father
fundamentally I'm positive I'm
personally and optimistic but they've
been pessimistic erosions of my optimism
let me ask you this though Abby you
wrote a book here a history of warfare
hmm you've written 20 books on history
you go back 4,000 you know what is it
about today that ever made you think
there was a shot at this thing worldwide
long-term peace because everybody
forgets about nuclear weapons I mean it
says it's made I mean you know the Cold
War's Odin a Berlin War lady came down
in 1989 everybody knew about nuclear
weapons in 1989 1994 they all seem to
have forgotten about them I mean they're
still there they're still threatened
anybody who tries to fight a really big
serious war with nuclear retaliation
that's the fundamental basis for either
genuine optimism or else a hopeless
person ISM well I'm not prepared to be
hopelessly pessimistic I didn't think
man's that stupid I didn't he I didn't
think well even I
I can't see any I can't visualize the
situation in which we need new car cells
into extinction
I think we'd find some way of not doing
that and that being the case nuclear
weapons must be seen as a means of
stopping big Wars and that is a great
relief to mankind sitting back array
1900 would you've ever envisioned 70
million people killed in two world wars
not in 1900 I think in between the wars
and 20s and 30s you hang on to hope for
the world with very very sort of fragile
fingernails ran got into the habit of
killing people in large numbers by
pretty brutal direct methods in the in
the 20th century civilized man did and
nuclear weapons said right
Bevo I like this look what's going to
happen but near the end if if you had to
pick a couple people in history that
you'd like to sit down and talk to
military people leaders of military
offenses and who would you pick
wellington the first you the great Duke
because he all that amazingly successful
Sodra never really defeated he had a
extremely
disdainful attitude to war rarely I
think he thought it was a necessary evil
he happened to be very good at it but I
don't think he he didn't Gloria more he
thought war was pretty horrible but
sometimes you had to do it and the also
he was a superb I think I'm fascinating
example of a particular human type he
was the sort of the ultimate ideal of
the Western gentleman the honor would be
Eisenhower who I addressed simply
because I admire him enormously as a
human being and he's if Wellington
epitomizes the sort of English gentleman
I'm Eisenhart epitomizes the natural
American gentleman the farm boy who who
whether with a a sort of religious
upbringing a deeply religious mother who
who never less is sort of quite a
character
small-town boy gazed Westpoint
acquires and education and then threw
responsibility becomes an extraordinary
as strongly as what of agent of power
throughout the world and yet never loses
touch with his think deeply good man and
good man who exercise power are ready
the most fascinating Hall people John
Keegan we're out of time thank you
author of a history of warfare thank you
very much indeed